et nous sommes avec carlo alberto brusa
avocat et analyste politique bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous depuis
cinquante ans cette région emilie
romagne est un fief de la gauche la
victoire donc du parti démocrate centre
gauche c'est pas vraiment une surprise
ce qui est beaucoup plus surprenant
c'est l'engagement que sabine y avait
pris d'une manière je dirais de traits
quasiment violente pour arriver à
vaincre et à battre la gauche dans cette
région et c'est un vrai échec parce
qu'il avait mis gérer tout son poids
physique moral humain politique privé à
retourner ces situations et ça c'est le
premier point donc le bassin res est de
gauche mais ce qui est très intéressant
ce que vous avez parlé des deux vraiment
deux défaites de solvin et moi je pense
que c'est plutôt un rééquilibrage
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons avec notamment
quelque chose que pour moi beaucoup plus
important aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le
moment cinq étoiles qui s'est écroulé
dire aujourd'hui dans les deux régions
n'oublions pas que nous avons un
gouvernement avec le parti la gauche
le et les 5 étoiles et aujourd'hui
vous avez 4% 5% aux 4,5 en attendant le
terme définitif à la romagne et en
calabre et vous avez là le vrai échec je
pense retentissant dans cette affaire on
peut pas vraiment parler de coup dur
pour matteo salvini part donc avec quand
même vous l'avez dit vous-même pris
l'engagement justement de s'imposer dans
cette région clé d'accès un coup dur
parce que tout a été fait pour que l'on
puisse arriver aux nouvelles élections
je pense que le résultat que nous avons
eu aujourd'hui en italie est un
soulagement pour l'europe est un
soulagement je dirais pour les marchés
financiers et le besoin d'une certaine
continuité côte unité qui va être encore
plus je dirais négative pour le moment
cinq étoiles c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
ressort victorieux et le parti
démocratique pourquoi pas ce que gagne
un luminaire man en calabre
les 20 points de différence entre quand
même la droite et la gauche
énorme surtout que ce n'est pas du tout
le une candidate de sa ville même si la
pluie est fortement
n'oublions pas il a fait quasiment du
porte à porte et bien de ce qu on ne
s'est quasiment pas déplacé alors que
c'est la candidate de force et talent
gagner là aussi c'est une preuve très
importante parce que la calabre c'est
avec la ccid l'une des régions les plus
touchées par la mafia à la corruption
on connaît pas au bras forge des
attentats quasiment quotidiens contre
contre les gens qui s'opposent à la
matière donc une situation je dirais de
rééquilibrage et il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui
selon moi c'est mon opinion personnelle
mais ce prochain que je m'exprime avec
force c'est que on n'est pas près
d'aller aux nouvelles élections pour le
moment alors ça c'était une volonté de
matteo salvini ainsi le remporta
justement si son parti remportait
l'élection dans cette région d'emilie
romagne il il s'était engagé justement à
apprenez de nouvelles pour éperonner
mais c'est pas seulement pour ça qu on
allait aux nouvelles élections
aujourd'hui je dirais même c c'est
l'échec de tous ses choix politiques
depuis que il avait quitté le
gouvernement pour tenter ce coup de
trafalgar pour arriver tout de suite de
nouvelles élections parce que il était
dans cette phase je dirais et comment
pratiquer sur le plan politique le
résultat le résultat c'est un échec
total sur le post
mais surtout le chèque est aussi un
échec du mouvement 5 étoiles qu'un
poursuivant la politique à travers je
dirais cette coalition extrêmement
hybrides parce que avec le parti
démocratique de la gauche a quand même
joué pour moi son devenir donc ça veut
dire qu'on va vers une poussée du parti
démocrate centre gauche
moi je pense que oui je pense que nous
avons un renouveau à renouveau du parti
démocrate centre gauche qui avec une
galette qui a changé c'est un virage
important je rappelle aussi que c'est un
peu le chèque aussi de matteo renzi il
espérait vraiment pesé lourd alors que
je peux vous dire ont changé j'ai pour
venir ici ce matin chez vous il a fallu
quand même que je puisse passer une
partie un peu de la nuit à avoir un peu
de choses
il était quasiment il n'a pas été invité
sur le plateau on a vu du savini on a vu
des y est on a vu quand même pas mal pas
mal de personnages mais pas un récit qui
est aussi un peu je dirais à travers
ceux de ce pays et le mouvement des
sardines qui s'est mobilisée justement
contre à la ligue de matteo salvini
contre l'extrême droite
est-ce qu'il a pesé dans cette élection
je pense qu'il ya une forte mobilisation
plus de 67% sur il a pesé et la chose
qui est très étonnant c'est que beaucoup
beaucoup d'années se disaient oui ce que
ce qui fait le poids dans les places ne
devait jamais aux urnes alors que là je
crois que le moment des sardines à peser
a joué énormément pour trois raisons
parce que on s'attendait pas j'ai dit à
une réaction populaire on attendait les
politiques classiques contre les
positions extrémistes de sa ligne alors
que là c'est un peu la place un peu
des gens comme vous et moi qui ont
décidé de dire je vois se battre contre
cette approche qui fait voir l'italie
comme un pays de district deuxièmement
c'est un moment extrêmement joyeux et
jeunes ce qui est très intéressant et je
pense que les soldes c'est très
intéressant d'analyser le vote le nombre
de votants pour cette élection je pense
que c'est une jeunesse qui est arrivé
aux urnes qu'on n'avait pas avant qu'ils
avaient effectivement quitté le paysage
est ma télé je vous prie donc je disais
en troisième point c'est que ceci me
donne de l'espoir pour un rééquilibrage
de l'italie parce que le on a parlé de
ça fait trop d'années qu'on parle de
populisme aujourd'hui elles viennent on
s comme partie publie sais ce que c'est
la nouvelle droite après une nouvelle
droite depuis cette conservatrice ce
qu'on veut mais un espoir de un plus
grand équilibre hermes et renouveau
démocratique
alors qu'est ce que vous me l'avez dit
vous avez suivi un peu les réactions
cette nuit matteo salvini et dans quel
état d'esprit il a une marge de
manoeuvre
battu il est déchu mais en même temps je
pense qu'il se réjouit se réjouit de la
défaite niveau 5 étoiles parce qu'à la
fin c'est ça qu'on va retenir
aujourd'hui à travers la démission de
l'imac est intervenue il ya des jours et
cette défaite qui place vraiment le mot
5 étoiles dans une position de minorité
extrême par rapport à ce qui est la
situation globale par rapport aux part
aux grands partis
cet échec lui peut plus donner de
l'espoir pour les élections parce que
pour survire des chiffres la ligue a
fait 31 22 98 et ensuite et 34 le pas
démocratique donc aujourd'hui les deux
forces en présence que nous sommes à
l'italie si on prend ce partage gauche
droite parce que c'est un peu ça les
coalitions ont fait vraiment un retour
et ça c'est assez intéressant de ce
bipolarisme que on avait un peu perdu
avec ce non seulement même si c'est
beaucoup carlo alberto brusa je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat et analyste
politique